nope none good evening ladies and
gentlemen Berlin a new study finds news
is becoming less serious and more boring
this is how the news looks on YouTube I
hey everyone I'm flow I'm proto welcome
to vows github bus Cade up or what's up
targets 14 to 34 year olds they spend
more time online than in front of the TV
so how are things looking at germany
since the election what's the breakdown
of votes in the Bundestag avoiding
resignations galore in the greens in the
fdp Green Party leader Claudio Houghton
parliamentary group leader Jurgen true
Tina both said they're stepping down the
show is produced in this Berlin studio
since July the team here has been
putting out one new episode a day slowly
and mont better known online as la Floyd
has become famous for his YouTube
channel he's one of five presenters on
vas Cade up there were no sheets from
the difference between a regular anchor
and me or at least my role in bosque job
is that I get away with being more
opinionated that's a food oncoming bus I
can also choose what I think is going to
really interest this generation of
viewers and I include myself in that and
how to best convey it the entertainment
value is not at the expense of content
when tallying the concept originated in
the US the youtube channel SourceFed was
their inspiration the late 1800s The
Legend of Jack the Ripper has intrigued
ladies and gents around the world musket
up uses a similar format of quick cuts
and everyday language the focus is on
current affairs the makers aim to
present serious issues in an accessible
way audience interaction is particularly
important the channel now has more than
130,000 subscribers at a video de
convention in Cologne some 8,000 fans
turned up to celebrate their favorite
YouTube stars
stuff cotton who works for the show is
convinced it's reaching young people who
want to have their voices heard now the
internet it's absolutely vital that
online news engaged with the viewer
that's the very point of the internet
and social media platforms and viewers
really do get into proper discussions
that's the important bit we're not
talking about some particle that has 7
comments underneath that it's more like
thousands it's a platform for young
people to explore issues and all of its
interactive news formats are growing
fast but does that spell the end for
more traditional news bulletins everyone
including young people should really
tune in to the traditional news
bulletins it's important to know what's
going on but shows like vez que de are
simply a bit fresher showed enough I
tend to watch the news more on youtube
or online than on TV I'd some fans
leaving Cindy dashed it I just find the
presentation really interesting it's not
boring for young people I just think
it's appealing it's fun to watch you
must faster cooking the show is just a
few minutes long each episode focuses on
one issue which is explained in detail
not see violence police violence or this
whole issue of homophobic propaganda and
Russia these are particularly
interesting issues for our generation
and there are things we want to talk
about from an emotional point of view
laphroaig and his team are still
experimenting getting the right balance
between serious news and entertainment
is not easy but it's the fans will have
the final say
[ __ ] says get involved